hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast messengers of the mind I am
Julia O'Rourke of labyrinths and I'll be
your moderator for today's event we have
some important announcements before we
begin the presentation this presentation
has been approved for a category 1
continuing medical education credit by
Loma Linda University if you are
interested in obtaining CMI's after
attending this presentation please click
on the get your free CME credits button
in the bottom left corner of the event
screen this webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the event you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can if you have any technical problems
viewing or hearing this presentation
please click on the support button at
the top right of your presentation
window or submit your problem for the
green Q&A button lower left I would now
like to introduce today's featured
speaker dr. Floyd bloom hello dr. bloom
good afternoon
Floyd ebloom MD is professor emeritus at
the Scripps Research Institute in La
Jolla California he was chairman
emeritus of the department of neural
pharmacology at the Scripps Research
Institute past president of the American
Association for the Advancement of
science former president of the Society
for Neuroscience and of the American
College of neuropsychopharmacology
former editor in chief of science from
1995 to 2000 director of behavioral
neurobiology at the Salk Institute for
Biological studies and chief of the
laboratory of neuropharmacology of the
National Institute of Mental Health dr.
Bluhm recently won the RSA Lifetime
Achievement Award at the research
society on alcoholism annual meeting in
June 2012 in San Francisco California I
will now turn it over to dr. bloom for
his presentation well thank you Judy and
good afternoon to everyone this
afternoon I want to tell you the story
of how neuroscientists came to accept
the concept that neurons speak to each
other can
luckily through the agents that we call
neurotransmitters before we begin I
should disclose that I'm a founder and
director of Alchemy's a company based in
Dublin Ireland and a director of two
other small companies but I won't
mention any of their products this
afternoon so you may be wondering and if
you're not wondering perhaps your
students will wonder why should they
study the history of neuroscience
well my concept is based on a book I
recently read called how we got to now
by Steven Johnson in which he makes the
point that history is worth telling
because it's a story that's true and
historically significant but it helps us
to see how things that we come to accept
is everyday common facts actually got to
be established studying the history of
neuroscience also helps us remember the
Giants who were our predecessors and on
whose shoulders we stand to see down the
road into the future and of course we
have to recognize that science is a
discipline done by human beings and as
human beings we often get things wrong
or we misinterpret the facts that we see
and I'll make these points perhaps time
and again Steven Johnson makes the point
that when something is a truly
historical event and changed the way in
which the future is unfold we see things
that we would not have come to expect
and we have unexpected consequences so
for example when Gutenberg invented the
printing press he also created a demand
for spectacles because until there was
something to read nobody knew that they
were nearsighted but having caused the
creation of spectacles he also
stimulated the production of lenses and
those lenses led to telescopes and
microscopes so the invention of the
printing press gave us the historical
developments that also drew drove the
science of our neuroscience now let me
quickly go through a timeline of some of
the major events in neuroscience
starting back in the end
the 18th century when Claude Bernard
investigated kirari he was the father of
experimental medicine and he did a lot
of experiments one of his experiments
was to take a frog nerve muscle
preparation bathe the nerve in curare
and observed that the nerve still worked
but when he bathed the muscle in kirari
the muscle did not work and clogged
bernard found that this process of
curare acting on the nerve muscle
preparation caused the muscle to be
paralyzed but he interpreted this in the
wrong way he actually interpreted
incorrectly he thought that kirari was
disconnecting the flow of vital fluids
from the spinal cord into the nerve the
nerves were regarded as hollow tubes
because they could see the myelin but
they couldn't see the axon pleasant in
between he got it wrong it wasn't
interfering with this flow of vital
fluids down the axon it was interfering
with the stimulation of the nerve
communicating with the muscle now when
we talk about chemical neurotransmission
credit is usually given to this German
with a French name and mildewed bhari
maang and what he actually said was that
well if it isn't electrical transmission
perhaps its chemical and for that he's
given credit but the real hero of the of
the story of chemical neurotransmission
has to be John Newport Langley he was a
scientist at Cambridge physiological
laboratories and he worked with a lot of
substances and tested them on the
British smooth muscle stimulus
preparations he had worked with the herb
that gave us pilocarpine and observed
that when he stimulated certain nerves
in the autonomic nervous system those
nerves reacted to them very similar to
what they would do when he put on
muscarine
and he observed that this vegetative
nervous system somehow could
discriminate the chemical signals
selectively
another big player in the system was
Ramona qahal who use Golgi stain to
identify neurons in the central nervous
system as individual cells and his cell
theory was quite at odds with what Golgi
interpreted which was the reticular
formation problem was that Golgi and
qahal didn't communicate with each other
and qahal only spoke Spanish when he
wrote his papers in Spanish no one could
read them and he was disappointed that
no one read them so he sent them to the
heads of states of the European
countries when they got to the United
Kingdom they were sent to the Royal
Society where they were finally seen by
Charles Sherrington a man whom we'll
come to in a moment but Sherrington was
an immediate fan of the cellular theory
and he recognized that qahal was an
important player and actually he's given
credit for inviting qahal later in the
end of the 19th century to come to the
Royal Society to talk about his cellular
theory the Langley Laboratory is given
credit for naming the autonomic nervous
system and Langley himself experimented
with a great deal of things including
the use of nicotine to stimulate the
autonomic nerves and to depolarize them
and to paralyze them and but that
combination of anatomy and pharmacology
and physiology which today we would call
neuro science Langley worked out the
detailed structure of the autonomic
nervous system and gave it its name he
also observed that when he took the
extract of the adrenal gland and put it
on certain smooth muscles they reacted
to those chemical substances exactly the
same way they would to the sympathetic
nerves being stimulated and from this he
advanced the case that there must be a
chemical neurotransmitter and the
peripheral nervous system one of his
students Thomas Eliot was given credit
for suggesting in fact that smooth
muscles reacted to the sympathetic
nervous system in the same way that they
did for the extracts of the adrenal
gland
although it wasn't exactly correct it
was a good step forward then Thomas
Langley him John Langley himself came up
with the idea that there must be certain
chemical substances on the surface of
these different smooth muscles and
glands that allowed them to react one
way when they were stimulated by a
cholinergic like substance and another
way when they're stimulated by a head
adrenal like substance and he called
these receptors he and Paul Ehrlich came
up with the concept at the same time
although airlock was given the Nobel
Prize for his conception of the receptor
system then one of the other faculty in
the Cambridge laboratory made the
observation that stimulating the vagus
nerve released something onto its target
structures that was very much like
muscarine did when they used the extract
of musk urine and from this we observed
the the idea that cholinergic and
adrenergic nerves populated the
parasympathetic and the sympathetic
nervous systems now we come to a yet
another student of the Cambridge
physiological labs Sir Henry Dale
Henry Dale was a medical student but
when he finished medical school he
wanted to get married so he took the
first job that he was offered in the
Wellcome research laboratories and when
he got there he was assigned to use the
forgot herb and to figure out what were
the substances that were contained in it
and in fact he did that and he
identified that forgot was able to block
sympathetic nerves and this was the
first adrenergic antagonist but he went
on to make several observations after
that another person who followed him
closely at the Cambridge physiological
labs was Charles Sherrington Sherrington
completed his medical studies and was
clinically qualified to practice but
instead he took a trip with two of his
classmates to Europe to investigate the
cholera epidemic and to understand how
vaccines were able to prevent that kind
of infectious disease he eventually
spent the whole year with Sir Robert
Koch who won a Nobel Prize
to study the mechanisms by which he
could identify which microbes cause
which diseases eventually Sherrington
returned to England qualified to
practice but he did not practice and he
became the superintendent of a
veterinary hospital where the animals
gave him the opportunity to pursue his
real interest which was the pathology of
brain diseases in the brain and in the
spinal cord when we get to the early
part of the 19th and 20th the 1910s you
see that Sir Henry Dale was able to
identify that synthetic noradrenaline
was much more like the sympathetic
nerves than the adrenal extracts had
been of course he didn't know that
depending on which animal species he
extracted from the adrenal glands he got
a mixture of epinephrine and
norepinephrine and although
norepinephrine was more like the
sympathetic nerves then epinephrine was
noradrenaline was thought to be a
synthetic substance and it wasn't known
that it was actually made naturally at
that time then world war ii came and
research came to a halt after the war
ended a pharmacologist in vienna named
otto lu v was trying to identify a way
in which he could prove that four vagus
nerve secreted something onto the heart
that was the chemical neurotransmitter
one night he had a dream he woke up from
the dream wrote down what he thought he
remembered and the next morning when he
woke up he remembered that he had had a
good dream but he couldn't remember what
the dream actually contained a few
nights later he had the same dream again
and this time so as to not take a chance
he got up and went to the laboratory so
he reported later and did the experiment
and the experiment that he did was to
take two frogs hearts stimulate one frog
and take the ringers solution that he
bathed the first frog Harden and
transfer it physically to the second
heart you can see on the right that when
he stimulated the first heart the first
heart slowed down and when he took the
liquid from the first heart and put it
onto the second heart
second heart after a delay also slowed
down he called this the chemical of the
vagus nerve vagus stuff and the vagus
stuff was the first chemical
physiological transmitter to actually be
proposed but the problem was that auto
Lully didn't really understand all of
the details of the experiment he had
done and he couldn't repeat his
experiment he took six years to repeat
his experiment and meanwhile several
people tried to repeat it in a different
way
some dogs instead of frogs and looked
what Lowell II didn't realize was that
by doing it in the springtime when he
did he was working with the strain of
frogs that were in winter season mode so
they were largely cholinergic but by
repeat trying to repeat it later in the
spring he couldn't do so because by that
time the frogs had adapted to the
weather and we're now a mixture of
sympathetic and parasympathetic many
people tried to repeat his experiments
using blood instead of ringers not
realizing that the vagus stuff would be
destroyed by the enzymes that were in
old blood but of course there are no
enzymes and ringers so honorably could
do it but he couldn't replicate it
because he didn't fully understand the
nature of what he had done then Sir
Henry Dale although not yet a sir found
that acetylcholine was a chemical that
occurred naturally in extracts of the
spleen he also at the same time
discovered that histamine natural
neurotransmitter could be extracted from
the spleen two of fales colleagues then
went on to show that if they'd
innervated the muscle it would react to
acetic choline in a much more sensitive
way than if it had been one of these
sympathetic muscarinic agents and so
they took this as a clue that the döner
baited muscle became super sensitive to
its neurotransmitter now at this point
world war ii was beginning to break out
the nazis had banned all jewish
scientists from working in
and laboratories and through a quirk of
fate the Rockefeller University agent
touring Germany managed to rescue serve
Feldberg because Sir Henry Dale had
asked him to be on the lookout for
Feldberg because Feldberg had an assay
for acetic choline they all wanted him
to join his laboratories in London then
he brought them here to do and within a
short time Phil Berg was able to
demonstrate that the Vegas stuff was
very much like acetone choline and
contained acid to a choline in fact and
at that point the opportunity to
identify the neurotransmitter as
acetylcholine in the autonomic nervous
system became valid and they soon found
that the acetylcholine could simulate
the actions of the cholinergic nerves
through the muscles by close inter
arterial injection unfortunately one of
the strong physiological antagonists the
idea of chemical neurotransmission was
John Eccles Eccles had been a medical
student in Australia and he interrupted
his clinical studies to go work with
Charles Sherrington Sherrington had
discovered among many things the reflex
arcs of the spinal cord and the process
of inhibition which was not very well
understood from the cities of the
autonomic nervous system but could be
seen in a reflex arc as the combination
of both an excitatory and inhibitory
message being communicated to different
circuits in the spinal cord equalist
couldn't explain inhibition but he was
very much against acetylcholine being a
chemical messenger because in his
experiments he had overdosed the muscle
with ezrin and esperan eliminated the
actions of acetylcholine because the
nerve became depolarized so that concept
of his that it had to be electrical
because it couldn't have been chemical
foster his research firm
years thing he couldn't explain was the
inhibition and we'll come back to that
in a moment but another of his
contemporaries was Walter B cannon a
medical student at Harvard University
who'd observed with the early
fluoroscope that when the animal became
agitated the intestine slowed down and
from this he began his studies of the
sympathetic nervous system and its
target innervations he had a very
complex idea about how epinephrine and
and sympathy which is what he called
sympathy e & symfon I worked one
sympathetic nerves activated stimulated
whereas other sympathetic nerves when
activated inhibited the contraction of
their smooth muscles he didn't quite
understand that but he came up with a
very complicated hypothesis to explain
it which no one else accepted either
unfortunately he didn't understand that
norepinephrine and epinephrine were two
different neural chemicals and when Lily
and Dale were awarded the Nobel Prize
for chemical neurotransmission
in the autonomic nervous system in 1936
Cannon was not mentioned at that time
because his complicated theory and his
persistence in stubbornness in not being
flexible about it may have offended
certain people in Sweden World War two
stopped a lot of research but didn't
stop research completely Stephen Kuh
Fleur who was working by that time with
Eccles in Australia used the new micro
electrode to record from neuromuscular
junctions and he observed that asset ill
coaling could simulate the action of the
art of the skeletal nerve to the muscle
and by closed intra-arterial injection
he observed that there was a delay
between the stimulation of the nerve and
the contraction of the muscle and that
time delay became very critical
simultaneously illinois ler working in
sweden identified that noradrenaline was
actually a natural substance and that it
was identical to what canon had called
his sympathy i at that point
Sir John echo
not yet uh sir again but working closely
in New Zealand came into contact with
the philosopher Karl Popper popper had
the belief that no scientific theory
could be proven but if he did the right
experiment you might be able to disprove
it and falsify the hypothesis so Eccles
came up with a paper that would explain
electrically his hypothesis of how the
inhibition of Charles Arrington's reflex
arcs actually came to pass and he
defined this in very rigid terms and
then he set about to do the experiment
that would prove that electrical
transmission was the way in which
central inhibition occurred
unfortunately the theory predicted one
thing and Eccles observed the other he
falsified his theory and so he came to
say well if it isn't electrical perhaps
it is chemical after all another person
in the time line of science that we must
mention is Jeffrey Harris Jeffrey Harris
was driven by the idea that somehow the
reproductive cycles of all animals was
driven by the environment that winter
and summer signals could clue the
reproductive system and he couldn't have
figure out how it was that the pituitary
which was by then thought to be the
source of the reproductive hormones
stimulating the gonads could be
controlled by something in the
environment and he said it must be the
brain that does it and he said about
stimulating the brain and showing that
the brain somehow communicated to the
pituitary and we'll come back to that in
just a moment
another important person at this time
was marked a vote who was working in
London and that identified that if she I
chopped up a dog's brain and I did
assayed four noradrenaline that
different parts of the dog's brain had
different amounts of noradrenaline that
it wasn't just the sympathetic nervous
system intervening the blood vessels of
the brain but that
noradrenaline had a separate existence
in the central nervous system julius
axelrod working at the National
Institutes of mental health wanted to
study the metabolism of norepinephrine
and he was able to have secure trittye
ated radioactive norepinephrine and he
injected into the bloodstream and was
amazed to find that almost
instantaneously it disappeared from her
bloodstream and when he chopped up the
body to figure out where the
noradrenaline had gone he found that it
was taken up by the nerve cells
sympathetic nerve cells in the target
tissues of the sympathetic nervous
system and from this he discovered the
reuptake system Rodger Gilman and Andrew
shally were postdoctoral fellows of hans
selye in montreal who was the so-called
father of the stress response and they
wanted to understand like Geoffrey
Harris how it was that the brain could
control the secretions of the pituitary
in this case stimulating the pituitary
to stimulate the adrenal cortex and they
began their quest for purification of
the pituitary driving hormones that the
brain secreted onto them their story is
much more extensive than I'm able to go
into this afternoon but the book the
Nobel duo by Nicholas Wade will tell you
about their competition and the many
errors they pick along the line for
example they both believed when they
started their quest for these factors
that they could not possibly be anything
but small molecules not not possibly to
be neuro peptides with which they turned
out to be and the mid-70s all Schneider
and several other investigators
identified that the brain carried
specific receptors for opiates and from
that became the quest for the natural
endogenous opioid peptides systems sir
hans cost relates and john hughes will
give him an alaska reward for their
identification of the endogenous
peptides called in Kevin's and Abram
Goldstein working at Stanford identified
yet another line of endogenous opioid
peptides which he called the
nor fiends not in Japan and Kyoto
doctors Numa and nakanishi
changed the entire process by which
materials were discovered they were able
to identify from pituitary glands the
messenger RNA for the pre opium
melanocortin gene the gene that gives
rise to both opioid peptides in the
pituitary and to the precursor of ACTH
in 1980 Thomas Hoch felt and his
colleagues in Stockholm were able to
showed with immunohistochemistry that
the neuro peptides such as the opioid
peptides occurred in neurons that also
contained small molecule
neurotransmitters and that neuro
peptides coexisted with those other
neurotransmitters a very revolutionary
concept that was very hard for many
people to accept at the time and one of
the last elements in this timeline that
we'll go into is dr. michele 'm and his
discovery of the endogenous
endocannabinoids the first called Amanda
Meyde and which represent the receptors
at which cannabis marijuana actually has
its effects on the brain
and we take that timeline and reduce it
we can see that there were many people
who played important but lesser roles
and several people who played major
roles and these seven scientists played
in my opinion the major roles and
bringing us to where we are today in
neuroscience chemical communication
Sir Charles Sherrington who discovered
reciprocal inhibition in the spinal cord
was a champion of the neuron theory from
the beginning his reciprocal innovation
identified the circuits and predicted
that there would be certain circuits
that are identical for excitation and
identical for inhibition and that both
excitation and inhibition worked at once
that the brain was not at rest waiting
for important excitatory signals to come
in but that it was in a dinette
equilibrium and call-to-action by
selectively augmenting inhibition or
excitation henry dale was the champion
of chemical neurotransmission from the
beginning he identified a scintilla : he
identified oxytocin histamine adrenergic
agents and antagonists
but he his one shortcoming was that he
didn't know that noradrenaline was a
natural substance and so he came close
to identifying the autonomic neurons
matters but not completely so John
Eccles the strong opponent of chemical
neurotransmission until he falsified his
own theory was perhaps the major driving
force for the next half of chemical
nerve transmissions history because once
he had recognized that it must be
chemical he raised questions that drove
the science for the next 50 years
what other chemicals besides nerve
besides a still choline could be
neurotransmitters how does the actual
neurotransmitter substance in the nerve
terminal get replenished when it gets
depleted by the nerve activity and how
is it that the cell surface of the
target tissue of a neuron or the muscle
or the gland is able to react what is it
that causes the change in excitability
of that target cell the gland or the
smooth muscle or the neuron his
questions drove Payton to identify
certain criteria for identifying what a
chemical neurotransmitter must be it has
to be shown that it can be present and
made by the presynaptic neuron it has to
have a process that is exactly like the
postsynaptic cell reacts to the
stimulation of the nerve and it can
reproduce in pharmacological terms the
transmission from nerve to muscle with
agents that simulate or antagonize it
and antagonists have to compete with
both the natural substance and any
substance that simulates its action
and Peyton said that none of these by
themselves will establish that a
neurotransmitter is the transmitter for
this circuit but the evidence of all of
them put together is what makes the
combination the most powerful proof that
this is the neurotransmitter now we'll
continue that with Axelrod julius
axelrod and Seymour Cuddy who are major
players in the establishment of chemical
neurotransmission they believed in the
mono amines norepinephrine serotonin and
Israel here from Arvid Carlsson dopamine
as well they were able to establish the
neurotransmitter transporters the
reuptake systems conserved the
neurotransmitter after it has been
released
dr. Katie was the first person to
propose the biological hypothesis of
depression and he later extended that to
mania and to schizophrenia he was the
first person to identify and study blood
flow in the brain and showed that the
oxygen was driven by neural activity as
was cerebral blood flow and he was the
first to ask whether the monoamine
transmitters could be because of the
neurotransmission that led to depression
and/or mania at the present time
scientists believed that chemicals do
cause the communication between neurons
that the synaptic activity secretes a
chemical agent that transmits the
activity from the presynaptic neuron
from the postsynaptic neuron and
pharmacologist believed that every new
neurotransmitter discovered represents a
whole new class of receptors perhaps
multiple classes of receptors and those
mechanisms are opportunities for a
therapeutic intervention medications can
be developed to simulate or antagonize
neurotransmitters when they are causing
disease by deficiency or by excess and
it is that belief that has driven most
of my research career
in fact when I first got to the NIH I
was given the opportunity to work with
five feral micropipette electrodes which
is a way to circumvent the blood-brain
barrier and apply putative
neurotransmitters to the surface of
neurons as they existed in the central
nervous system unfortunately the results
of this early experiment the
pharmacology of individual neurons was
that about 1/3 of the cells would
respond with excitation to anything that
was switched on them one third would
respond by inhibition which spritzed on
them and one third would respond by not
responding at all and it seemed to me
that just asking whether a neuron would
respond to a substance was not the key
question the key question was where is
the neurotransmitter presynaptic
terminal on this cell and what chemicals
does it contain and my goal had been to
study norepinephrine and so you'll see
here ten different ways that over the
years we have come to develop methods
for doing visualization of Norfolk
afferent so we can see its synaptic
terminals in the brain and one of the
places that we chose to study this with
george Sagan's and very Hoffer in the
early 70s was in the cerebellum because
Sir John Eccles and his colleagues had
made that the best understood place in
the brain for synaptic transmitter
circuitry and so when we applied Noor
for nephron and later on when we
stimulated its origins and the locus
coeruleus we found that we could
simulate all the effects of
norepinephrine by five Beryl
micropipettes doing agonist we could
block the effects of the locus coeruleus
and the effects of applied
norepinephrine with beta adrenergic
blockers and we could extend the effects
of norepinephrine through ad noelite
cyclase by stimuli by releasing closely
cyclic AMP E or chemicals which would
extend the lifetime of cyclic AMP E and
I have because of the limits on time
this afternoon eliminated all of the
g-protein coupled receptor discussion
but another major major chapter in our
history of chemical
mission is represented by that now
having identified that norepinephrine
could simulate the effects of the locus
coeruleus Gary Aston Jones and Steve
Foote studied the locus julius's
discharge rate in awake behaving rats
and in awake behaving monkeys and they
found that the locus coeruleus would
respond rapidly to any novel stimulus in
its environment and that this novel
stimulus caused the locus coeruleus to
activate its synaptic transmitter
systems and circuits all over the
central nervous system when we look at
the synapse we can see that when the
locus coeruleus is firing at low rates
it activates alpha adrenergic receptors
which have a high nerve receptor
affinity and when they stimulate
physically they simulate the beta
adrenergic receptors which is what we
observed in the cerebellum so the entire
system from the locus coeruleus to its
synapses in terminals throughout the
central nervous system gave us an
opinion that norepinephrine could be the
neurotransmitter for causing focused
attention and Gary Aston Jones and John
Cohen have elaborated this in a theory
of the nor epinephrine adrenergic
circuits being attention gaining
circuits now let's return to their seven
key players Jeffrey Harris driven by the
idea of what causes reproductive cycles
to be driven by environmental signals he
thought that if he stimulated the brain
and the brain was controlling the
pituitary he might be able to release
hormones from the pituitary so he
studied the thyroid system because with
radioactive iodine he could know when
thyroid gland was active and he found
that when he stimulated the brain in
fact when he stimulated discrete spots
in the hypothalamus he could drive the
secretion from the pituitary of a
hormone that would stimulate the thyroid
gland but he said there are no nerves
from the brain to the pituitary how does
it communicate those signals he was
fortunate to come into contact with the
Romanian scientists
who told him about the pituitary portal
system and so he was able to show the
pituitary portal system was a series of
blood vessels from the base of the brain
to the from the hypothalamus to the
pituitary and they thought that perhaps
through this portal circulation brain
factors could be secreted that would
then selectively drive the glands of the
anterior pituitary the posterior
pituitary was connected by nerves to the
oxytocin and vasopressin neurons and the
super optic in pairs para sympathetic
ganglia of peri-peri parvocellular
ganglia of the hypothalamus and those
stimulations caused them to be secreted
but if there was chemicals released from
the brain to drive the anterior
pituitary gland it would be difficult to
find those and so Andrew shaly and Roger
Gilman and along with Don McCann at
Southwestern University began a quest by
going to the butcher houses of Texas
where they were able to get millions and
millions of brains and eventually
millions and millions of hypo-thala my
and to use those in extracts with giant
sephadex columns to try to purify these
protein factors from the hypothalamus
eventually they were able to do so but
it took more than 50 tons of sheep
hypothalamus to deliver one milligram of
the thyroid thyroid rope and releasing
factor which caused the anterior
pituitary to release
thyrotropin-releasing hormone to
stimulate the thyroid gland first neuro
peptides that were discovered in this
way with the tripeptide for thyrotropin
releasing factor almost the last one to
be discovered was discovered by Wally
Vale the correct rope and releasing
factor unfortunately while avail was
lost to neuroscience by his early death
in 1971 I led a session at the
neuroscience research program
it was designed to ask whether amino
acids and polypeptides could possibly be
neurotransmitters we had some of the
Giants of the of the neuroscience
community attending this conference and
they gave their very strident views and
after a series of discussions it was
concluded that well perhaps neuro
peptides might be considered to be
neurotransmitters but glutamate and
aspartate and gaba couldn't possibly be
because every nerve cell that was
responding to glutamate was excited and
every nerve cell that was tested with
gaba was inhibited these actions were
thought to nonspecific and in fact it
was said well how could a neuron
possibly keep the glutamate that it uses
for protein synthesis separate from the
glutamate that it uses for
neurotransmission and again the
neuroscientists of the day were quite
wrong we see in this graph a curve of
the growth of the discovery of neuro
peptides largely driven by chemical
processes that identified the features
of neuro peptides there c-terminal am
adacia n-- i've used the names of them
so that you can't actually read them
because nu or peptides were given names
for where they were discovered or what
they did in their first action but later
were found to be all over the brain and
to give rise to actions that were not
described by the names that they were
given originally such as somatostatin
which inhibited growth hormone when
released in the pituitary but because a
brain neurotransmitter everywhere
the last person of the seven i want to
mention is dr. Numa of Kyoto University
he and his colleague nakanishi described
in this nature paper in 1979 that by
taking the pituitary intermediate glands
from 40 different cows 40 animals only
he was able to identify the messenger
RNA that contained the gene that gave
rise to the Pearl Opio melanocortin
hormone he and not candy she later went
on to
describe the messenger RNAs and the gene
structure for the sodium channel and the
calcium channel and by their use of
molecular biological techniques they
were able to totally reverse the way in
which neuro peptides and other brain
derived factors were being discovered
instead of looking for proteins to be
purified they were able to identify them
completely by isolating their messenger
RNAs and many a scientists have used
this technique including my colleague at
Scripps Gregg cyclic to identify many
important genes if the brain makes as
chemical signals these are the
structures of the first three opioid
peptides families the pro opl
melanocortin discovered by not ganesha
and numa the pro Metron Kathlyn discard
by Hans Cassavetes and John Hughes and
the prodynorpin described by Avram
Goldstein but in fact there are other
genes that make opioid peptides as well
although time does not permit me to go
into them this afternoon Thomas
hope-filled described the peptide
neurons in the autonomic nervous system
and then in the brain in which his
neuropeptide was accompanied by gaba or
glutamate or norepinephrine or dopamine
or serotonin at first this was very hard
to believe but electron microscopy has
later demonstrated that the neuro
peptides are occurring in small granular
and in large granular vesicles and in
nerve terminals can also contained small
vesicles that contain the more classical
small molecule neurotransmitters this
line of research has recently been
extended by maricella Morales at the
National Institute of drug abuse who
showed that dopamine neurons in a
certain select sub population can also
release either glutamate or gaba
complicating the coexistence property
but making it one of the more compelling
questions of neurotransmitters that we
face today so at the beginning of this
century we scientists knew I put new in
quotation marks because what we know
often is changed by new facts we knew
that there were neurotransmitters that
were amino
there were mono amines or neuropeptides
but that there were also other chemicals
that neurons could use to communicate
for example their neurotransmitter like
substances stored in vesicles such as
ATP and is N and Dennison as discovered
by Geoffrey Byrne stock but there were
also materials that are formed on demand
such as the prostaglandins and the
endocannabinoids that are not stored in
vesicles and that perhaps even gases
like nitric oxide or carbon monoxide or
hydrogen sulfide can be used by neurons
to signal to the neurons to which they
are connected one of the most compelling
examples of these other
neurotransmitters is the lactate
hypothesis developed by Pierre
Magistrate a and his colleagues in
Lausanne magistrata observed that
glucose utilization by the brain is
sometimes in excess of oxygen
utilization and he had discovered that
neurons in certain parts of the brain
and undergo a aerobic metabolism Ivar
Berg in which glucose is metabolized to
lactate and the lactate is converted to
pyruvate which then enters the
tricarboxylic acid cycle and can
generate 17 molecules of ATP 4-month
molecule of lactate to pyruvate
whereas when it's just glycolytic
metabolism only two molecules of ATP are
constructed from each molecule of
lactate he observed that when neurons
excite each other the glutamate that
they secrete to excite is taken up by
extra sites and the astrocytes convert
that glutamate to lactate which they
then feed to the neurons as their energy
source in fact the lactate that glia
secrete the signal and provide energy to
neurons can be confused to control a
wide variety of things that include
plasticity and all of the genes that
underlie plasticity neural degeneration
and perhaps even the amyloid hypothesis
is in part derive from the default
circuits in the brain that use aerobic
glycolysis as their preferred method of
energy production and it's through this
signaling activity drawing glucose and
oxygen to the site gives rise to the
magnetic resonance imaging methods of
functional connectivity imaging that
you'll hear in some of the other talks
later today and tomorrow
so through histo chemistry electro
physiology and pharmacology we
understand neurotransmitter systems we
can identify precisely their anatomic
projections we can identify their
behavioral repertoire but suppose five
years from now when david von essen's
connectome project reaches its peak we
know all of the neuro circuits in the
brain all of the neurotransmitters all
of their cellular routes and all of
their methods of firing and response to
environmental and internal signals now
that we know that what is it we know and
how can we build on that to explain how
the brain does what I'm doing with you
this afternoon communicating in words
thoughts that are complex and creative
and hopefully inspiring to you how can
we build upon this knowledge to identify
how those abstract properties of brain
and behavior emerge from these details
of chemical communication and cellular
chemicals signaling now I began with
this talk with a mention of Claude
Bernard in the 18th century let me take
you back even further to the painting of
the Sistine Chapel by Nicole Angelo
Buonarroti at the beginning of the
sixteenth century this is a painting
from the ceiling of the Sistine Chapel
in which we can see the Creation of Adam
in 1990 a physician named Frank mesh
Berger looked at this painting and said
isn't it strange that God's cloak is
shaped like the human brains cortex
and isn't it funny how God's me is
sticking out exactly where the optic
chiasm would be and isn't it funny that
that scarf is exactly how the vertebral
artery would be and he identified that
nickel Angelo had hidden in his painting
of the Sistine Chapel the human brain by
which it is thought michelangiolo meant
to communicate that God not only gave
Adam life but he gave him the
intelligence of the human being so I ask
you in conclusion when God touches Adam
was this perhaps the first synapse and
those are my views of the messengers of
the mind and I'd be pleased to answer
any questions that may have emerged in
the audience and thank you and good
afternoon thank you dr. bloom for that
informative presentation your audience
will now have the opportunity to ask you
some questions before we get started on
the question and answer session I would
like to remind the audience how to
submit questions you can't submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green few and a button at the lower left
of the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can the
first question yes
is it possible to promote practical
neurogenesis in the brains of
individuals who are in their 90's and
are there recent publications
well the question of neurogenesis in the
brain is an interesting one and again
it's another example of how initially
scientists got it wrong we thought that
as the brain finished development in
early infancy that no new neurons were
born but scientists have simple
subsequently discovered that
neurogenesis can be stimulated and that
certain stem cells persist in the brain
can continue to generate neurons in
certain parts of the brain and indeed
there are scientists who believe that it
will be possible eventually to stimulate
these not so much in the aged brain
alone but in brains as we pass through
adulthood to keep the brains vital and
dynamic it is true that neurogenesis has
a natural phenomenon decays with age but
we don't yet have a good way to control
that to do it therapeutically as an
intervention your listeners were
engrossed in your presentation and I'm
going to give them a few more moments to
ask you some questions thank you know
what we we are nearing the end of our
session so I think we're going to wrap
up now and and close we are out of time
I'm so sorry unfortunately they have
questions they can email me and I'll try
to answer them so I want to thank the
audience and for their participation for
attending today's event and I'd like to
thank our speaker of course dr. bloom
for being here today and for his
enlightening presentation today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing for several months following you
or seen an email from lab roots alerting
you when this webcast will be available
for replay we invite you to afford that
announcement to your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event see you
next time goodbye